how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to the M see you today we have
a Captain Marvel to plat leak and if
this ends up being true then Captain
Marvel 2 is definitely going to be
better than the first Captain Marvel as
always with all supposed plot leaks that
we get I must issue a spoiler warning if
this is legitimate it's going to contain
some major spoilers for Captain Marvel -
including some new characters that could
be coming to the MCU and the villain and
we're gonna dive into this new leak and
break it down if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the MCU and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 now as with all
leaks this comes from an anonymous
source because obviously somebody is
connected to the film they can't have
their name out there on a plot leaked
but it starts off by saying Marvel has
had meetings with multiple female
directors about helming the project now
the first Captain Marvel film was
directed by Anna Boden and Ryan Fleck
and it has been reported that there is
going to be a new director for Captain
Marvel 2 and it seems like Marvel's
going to stick with having a female be
the director of the film it goes on to
say that the release date is currently
unknown however Marvel is positioning it
for a 2022 release this means that
Captain Marvel is probably going to be
one of the first releases of the phase 5
lineup and that means that
pre-production for Captain Marvel 2 is
most likely not that far away so we
should be finding out a lot more about
the film very soon sword is the central
focus of the movie samuel l jackson and
Cobie Smulders are returning to reprise
their respective roles as Nick Fury and
Maria Hill ben mendelsohn will also be
returning as Talos and Jude Law will be
returning as Yann raagh now sword was
actually revealed at the end of
spider-man far from home in the
post-credits scene
now sword stands for sentient world
observation and response department they
are basically shield but instead of
focusing on earthly threats they focus
on extraterrestrial threats so they are
a space-based counterpart to shield and
just like Nick Fury ran shield it looks
like him and Murray Hill are going to be
running sword as well and as we just saw
in the post-credits scene there are
plenty of scroll on what is known as the
peak or Nick furious so humans and the
scroll are now working together so it
makes sense that Tallis is returning
especially since we saw him and
spider-man far from home the leak goes
on to say that the film will deal with
Carol Danvers as an official agent of
sword assembling the a force to fight
against a massive cosmic threat well
Nick Fury is back from being decimated
and it seems like he is running sword
now and given the fact that him and
Carol Danvers have a really really
strong relationship and considering the
fact that the last time we saw Carol
Danvers was on earth fighting Thanos it
would make sense that she has now become
an official agent of sword now the a
force is simply an all-female Avengers
team which Carol Danvers is apparently
going to assemble in this film and
according to this leak the a force
members are going to be Miss Marvel
she-hulk Spider Woman Scarlet Witch
Mighty Thor who we can assume is Jane
Foster as the female Thor Valkyrie and
spectrum now there are a few new
characters in this list of a force
members Miss Marvel and she-hulk who of
course have been announced to be getting
their own Disney Plus series Jane Foster
Thor who of course is going to be
introduced and for love and thunder in
phase four but then we have Spider Woman
and spectrum now recently we've heard
reports that Marvel is developing a
Spider Woman movie so perhaps she'll be
introduced in Captain Marvel 2 as part
of the a force and then get her own solo
film and then we have spectrum now
spectrum is Monica Rambeau who we saw in
the first Captain Marvel film she is the
daughter of Maria Rambo and Monica
Rambeau is already confirmed officially
by Marvel Studios to be appearing in the
Wanda vision series
now it's also confirmed by some leaked
photos that sword is going to be in the
Wanda vision series as well so there are
some major connections here now in the
comics Monica Rambeau was introduced as
a second captain Marv
who gained her powers from extra
dimensional energy and since sword is
going to be involved and located in
space it would make sense that this
extra dimensional energy that Monica
would get would most likely be from
space and most likely due to her working
force sword the leek says that the
Disney Plus Series Secret Invasion will
tie into the film the series will
explore a group of scroll refugees
hiding out on earth and being pursued by
a squadron of Kree sleeper cells led by
Yann
raagh as well as the remaining members
of star force the main character of the
Disney Plus series will be hoechlin a
Kree scroll hybrid who has taken the
identity of Teddy Altman a normal high
school student hoechlin will also cameo
in one division and will be a major
character in Captain Marvel - now we've
already had the report that whole
cleanable cameo in one division and
that's most likely due to his connection
to Wiccan one of the sons of Wanda in
the comics now hoechlin is not the
offspring of the Hulk even though it
definitely sounds that way he is
actually a scroll who has the ability to
shape-shift into something like the Hulk
and he also has superhuman strength it's
important to note that hoechlin is one
of the Young Avengers which of course is
being set up for the MCU right now but
it's also a major part of Secret
Invasion and so is Captain Marvel which
explains the tie-in to the movie now a
Secret Invasion Disney Plus show is a
lot better than a Secret Invasion movie
and a lot of people have expressed this
recently The Secret Invasion storyline
is definitely interesting however Marvel
in the MCU changed the scroll in the
comics the scroll were bad and they
infiltrated earth a shape-shifting into
other members of the Avengers and Secret
Invasion was all about finding out who
they were but now in the MCU the scroll
are good so it doesn't really warrant a
movie but a Disney Plus show will
definitely be interesting if it stars
the hoechlin but here's where the leak
says that things get very interesting
Megan MacDonald who is one of the
writers for the one of vision series and
has officially been hired to write the
script for Captain Marvel 2 has
apparently pitched the script for
Captain Marvel 2 as heavily inspired by
aliens and a Space Odyssey and almost a
cosmic horror and this really actually
does fit with what is happening here
because sword is located in space
Captain Marvel was roaming the galaxy in
the five-year period between the snap
and a vendor's endgame so she's already
explored the galaxy and the scroll are
involved so it really is a Space Odyssey
with aliens
the film will deal with the sword base
being compromised by a rare alien threat
that threat is the brood who are laying
eggs on the sword base and our
possessing agents now this is basically
a twist on secret invasion the brood
infect people and take over their bodies
the person that the brood takes over
dies and the brood puts its
consciousness into the body
so basically secret invasion and now it
makes sense that they made the scroll
good because without the scroll we were
wondering how could they do a secret
invasion well it seems like their plans
were to use the brood which now makes a
lot of sense as it turns out only male
agents can get compromised which leads
to the formation of the a force now this
seems to be a way that's going to make a
lot of different people happy it'll make
people who have been waiting for the a
force team very happy to see that
they're finally going to be in a movie
but a lot of people have complained that
Captain Marvel was a little bit too
feministic but if this plot leaked ends
up being truth and there's a very very
good reason that the a force is
assembling and the lineup for the a
force team is pretty freakin awesome so
it'll definitely be exciting to see them
come to the MCU Carol and the other
female heroes of the Marvel Universe
must stop the spread of the brood and
their influence across the galaxy it
turns out that the species are operating
as parasites and have been secretly
conquering planets in the universe in
order to kill them they must kill the
Empress brood which means going to their
home planet
now the Empress brood controls all of
the other broods they follow her orders
and she has telepathic abilities that
she uses to talk to all of the other
brood however she does not have full
control over all of the broods so they
can rebel against her but essentially if
the brood are taking over the galaxy and
the universe if you kill the Empress you
stop the entire brood now Captain Marvel
some of her best stories are based in
space and some of her greatest villains
are cosmic villains
and Kevin Feige has already confirmed
that the future of the MCU is in the
cosmos the MCU is going to space
originally before his firing and then
rehiring James Gunn was supposed to take
the MCU into space with guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 and also him given his
input on other films but there's been a
delay
that since he has to finish everything
involved with the new Suicide Squad
movie that is coming out so we'll be
going into the cosmos before guardians
of the galaxy vol 3 and according to
this plot leak
Captain Marvel 2 is going to take us
there with the a force the final thing
that this leak says is that the film is
going to be similar to thor ragnarok and
will take place 95% in space a complete
tonal and visual departure from the
original now of course the first Captain
Marvel didn't take place entirely on
earth in fact the beginning was in space
at the kree's home planet but of course
they had to go back to earth because
they had to talk about Carol Danvers as
origin and she's from Earth but now we
got that out of the way and now Captain
Marvel can go explore the cosmos and if
there's going to be a tonal shift and if
it's going to be somewhat like Thor
Ragnarok then not only is it going to be
a super cool cosmic movie but it's also
probably going to be kind of funny and
fun fact about the brood it's been
implied that they cannot infect people
that have advanced healing abilities for
example one time an egg was implanted in
Deadpool and instead of turning into a
brood a small brood burst out of
Deadpool's body now I'm not sure if
Marvel's planning a cameo for Deadpool
in Captain Marvel - but that would
certainly be a really good way to do it
but let me know what you think about
this plot League for Captain Marvel -
and let me know what you think about a
possible Secret Invasion Disney Plus
show coming be sure to let me know all
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video if you
enjoyed it and subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 and
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers don't forget
to follow me on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof